hello and welcome to the week three
fantasy football live presented
by State Farm
my name is Adam Levitan of
establishtherun.com as always as long as
the fam Folks at Bishop will have us I'm
joined by Michael Leone for this
Thursday 30 minutes fantasy football
show leonie how's it going today
good you know we too was a little kinder
to me than week one and uh looking
forward to week three now yes big bounce
back for a lot of the season long bags
there in week two was good to see on
today's show we are going to go over
some players we might consider trading
for some players we like rest of season
before we get into that though wanted to
get to some of your questions I know you
guys are dying for our opinion on some
of these questions Leone I want to get
right into it with Ariel Ariel says
should I trade Keenan Allen and Devonte
Smith
for Kyron Williams and Calvin Ridley now
this sounds ridiculous in the first
place right like Keenan Allen and
Devonte Smith were both round two round
three picks Kyra Williams was a waiver
wire pickup however Carl Williams played
76 of 80 snaps after Kim Acres was
deactivated for the last game I don't
think people understand in today's NFL
running backs don't do this they don't
play 76 out of 80 snaps at most running
backs are playing 40 50 snaps over on
the majority of them to get to 76 is
absurd I'm not saying that's going to be
every week but we shouldn't be holding
on to our priors I think on Kyron
Williams so Leonia what do you think
about that trade
yeah it's definitely closer than you
would have ever imagined a couple weeks
ago I do still worry that you're you
know buying high on Kyron Williams where
they just got rid of Cam acres and
moving forward we might not see that
snapshare quite as high I do have some
concerns that you know as good and
healthy as Matthew Stafford looks right
now that this Rams team at a certain
point in the season can start to dwindle
and have some o-line issues and whatnot
so I think I'll take the Devonta Smith
Keenan Allen side of things but like if
you're absolutely starved at running
back and you've got no one to start I
kind of see it but if you're looking at
like Kyron Williams in the flats versus
King nail and I still want the Keenan
Allen side of that things and I think
Devonta Smith and Calvin Ridley are
pretty close to one another a hundred
percent I agree you can always find our
rest of season top 150 at establish the
run.com we have Keaton Allen well ahead
of Kyra Williams in their rankings there
and I agree with that not just because
he plays running back and he's more
susceptible to injury he's more
susceptible to being replaced but just
is on a raw scoring output from week to
week I'll go ahead and take the other
side of that KV says should I trade away
where he mostert to get Breece hall now
I thought the time to celebrate Hall was
before last week he was coming off of
such a good game in week one week two he
was playing Dallas where we knew that
the Jets had absolutely no shot briefs
was going to face plant there and he did
so I don't know that now is exactly the
right time to sell briefs he's going to
have better performances he's going to
get healthier Zach Wilson will have
better games although not good games I
don't think that said I have major
concerns about Bree's rest of season I
don't think I give him up for most dirt
here but selling Brees is something I'm
interested in Leoni what do you think
about this one Breeze for moster
yeah I think I take Brees over mostert
here and some of these questions are
hard because like if you're just looking
at median fantasy points who's going to
score more the rest of the season it
might be boaster right he has the better
role right now he's on the better
offense but if you're looking at who's
more likely to win you your fantasy
league come crunch time towards the end
of the season you want to bet on kind of
the younger extremely talented breakout
type player in Bruce Hall regardless of
the offensive context around him so
Eileen Breese Hall as a result of that
like I wouldn't I mean I would have most
your favorite doubts or Breeze Hall over
the next four to five weeks so if it's
super critical for you get those short
term points I get it but I'm always
taking the swings on the upside like the
guys that could really if it breaks
right even if it's not super high profit
bill you could swing the league
completely in your favor and that's
going to be Breeze Hall here it to me
it's a question of do they replace Zack
Wilson I mean do they replace Zach
Wilson because if they don't I have
major concerns about Breeze hall for the
entire year if they do even with someone
who's not that good Jacoby brat
um Jameis Winston uh Ryan Tannehill if
they replace Zach Wilson with someone
like that I'll be super excited about
Bruce on I think that's definitely a
good chance
hberg's finest he says should I drop
Kyle Pitts or Dalton Kincaid for Evan
Ingram now I'm not sure what kind of
League Evan Ingram uh is on waivers and
I know he hasn't had the greatest start
to the year but he did catch six balls
last week uh I doubt evidence on the
waiver on many uh leagues but maybe for
everyone Leonia how would you think
about guys like Kincaid right now versus
Evan Ingram
yeah I feel like I'm getting trolled you
know these are all the guys that I loved
in the the preseason that haven't
started off super well with uh priest
Hall and Kyle Pitts now here and I do
feel somewhat similar to what I just
said about Breece Hall where I think if
you were just gonna say like projected
points for us to season Evan Ingram
versus Kyle Pitts that Ingram probably
outscores him you know the majority of
the time but there's just enough
outcomes where Kyle Pitts and his unique
talent I think just shows the ceiling
that Evan Ingram can't that I leaned
towards keeping pits but I think like
all three players are really close I've
been a Dalton Kincaid Stan
um you know I'm a Bill's Homer and his
route share was down last week but it
was awesome week one and it seems like
he's kind of he's gonna get you four to
five catches a week which doesn't sound
like a lot but at the tight end position
that type of consistency is nice and one
of these weeks he's going to throw some
efficiency alongside that volume so I
think all three are pretty close but I'd
I'd give pits one more week before
ditching him
I'll disagree I I think Arthur Smith
does not think that Kyle Pitts has that
much talent because the stuff is getting
schemed not for Kyle Pitts it's getting
schemed for other guys Mac Hollins
Johnny Smith I think Drake London is is
a more priority in this scheme than Kyle
Pitts is so I would have it ranked Evan
Ingram won Kyle Pitts two gonkin Kate
I'm sorry everything from one stone
Kincaid two uh Kyle Kyle Pitts three I
actually like the role uh for Don
Kincaid right now
all right
appreciate all the questions from you
guys in chat we are going now to move to
some players that we think might be
worth trading for or picking up off the
wire in your league if they have to be
on the wire we'll go ahead and start
with one in Justin fields from a real
life perspective Justin Fields has been
broken this year I mean bad looks like
not in the NFL quarterback
I'm not sure that's ever going to change
but from a fantasy perspective people
are like wanting to drop Justin fields
for pocket passers that's not it to me
Justin Fields can still run for 100
yards in a football game which gives you
an outrageous outrageous outrageous
ceiling and I think Luke getsy sees now
if he tries to turn Justin Fields into
something that he's not I.E we're not
going to design runs we're going to
throw short a lot that's not Justin
fields you have to go back into what
Justin Fields does well run with the
football in his hands and throw the ball
deep and I think that the Bears will see
that now that they're buried and so I
like training for Justin Fields this
week when everybody in the world has
given up on him Leone do you have any
hope left for Justin Fields this season
yeah I've got Hope just like you said
it's one of those situations where the
real life sentiment doesn't really match
up with the fantasy sentiment and he's
gonna run more assuredly moving forward
he's only averaging 31 rush yards per
game so far last year he's up at 76.
don't expect him to be at 76 again like
that was absolutely Bonkers but 55 60
rush yards with a rushing touchdown
every other week or so you know that is
going to get it done especially if
you're in a standard League where it's
you know four points per passing
touchdown one point per 25 yards you can
just totally dust even these guys that
throw for 302 with an elite game on the
ground
next guy that I think is interesting to
trade for or pick up is one that might
actually be on your wire right now and
that is Kendry Miller now Kendra Miller
was a rookie Prospect who I think was
kind of split in terms of what people
thought of him coming out but I think
that's kind of irrelevant because the
Saints thought enough of him to use a
third round pick on him which is
reasonably high for running back
and I think they now regret giving Jamal
Williams the bag I mean I love Jamal
Williams seems like a great guy I've
been featured on his Instagram which was
insane but anyways uh we're close
personal friends now me and Jamal
Williams however Tremont Williams is not
that good at football I mean he's just
not he scored 17 touchdowns last year
based on the Lions getting knocked out
at the one yard line in an outlier
amount of times they've seen this year
he's not that good now he's a hamstring
injury
suspended one more game Tony Jones is
Not really an NFL player he's more of a
borderline I would say NFL player
since he's a third round pick on Kendra
Miller who has a ton ton ton of juice
he's backpacking full this week it would
not Shock me if before the end of the
year it's actually Kendrick Miller who
is the 1A
alongside Alvin Kamara Alvin Kamara in
the pass down role Kendra Miller and
more of the bass rolls so if your league
is deep enough if your bench is deep
enough I like adding and holding on to
Kendra Miller and honestly you have to
start him this week I honestly don't
think it's that bad because jamalium is
going to miss Diamond Kamara is still
suspended so I've kind of been an island
on this Leone I don't think many people
are that interested in Kendra Miller uh
what do you think about him rest of
season
no yeah I mean I don't have a ton to add
there like it's just you want to take
advantage of these situations with
uncertainty and the uncertainty
generally favors the younger unproven
player that's kenray Miller here we know
Jamal Williams isn't it he does some
stuff coaches like but he's not going to
be super efficient there's question
marks around Alvin Kamara that's more
likely to go you know South than it is
north at this point in his career so
take the gamble on the rookie who we
don't know a lot about and you can
always move on from him but if he has a
big week this week you're not going to
be able to get him off waivers next week
or it's going to be a chore too it's
always important in your league to be a
week ahead of time take the gamble when
it's more uncertain but when it's
cheaper and then you can just move on if
it doesn't work out 100 I mean 100 is a
big week for Kendra Miller I agree
yeah and then as you can say you know
we've got Tony Pollard next on this list
and Adam his role has been
absurd I know last week uh in my
expected fantasy points model spit out
33 expected fantasy points for him he
only scored 17 but dude had eight
targets 25 carries six goal line carries
I think that's his second straight week
getting six carries inside the 10-yard
line which was sort of the only question
mark on him coming in so even though
this is a buy high it's it's the correct
by high I think if you can get someone
in your league to sell you off Tony
Pollard I mean I was asking all summer
why isn't Tony Pollard a consensus round
one pick why why I I don't get it it
doesn't make any sense oh well Rico
daudel and and and and Ronald Jones are
going to steal goal line work Adam don't
you know oh he he can't hold up to the
workload I mean
guys just like looking a gift horse in
the mouth with Tony Potter and if anyone
out there wants to sell Tony Pollard
right now it's an elite combination of
scheme role and environment I would be
buying on Tony Pollard
one another next one that kind of looks
like a sell High I mean I'm sorry that
looks like a buy high is Michael Pittman
and I gotta be honest I was not in on
Michael Pittman over the summer I don't
think I drafted Michael Pittman more
than maybe uh once or twice I probably
did like 70 drafts
um if you include basketball and I
probably only took Michael Pittman once
or twice
the way that the Colts are playing
the fastest Pace in the league
throwing a lot on first downs a way
higher pass rate of expectation than
expected
it's good for Michael Pittman and these
rpos are like go to Michael Pittman a
ton and so
I I don't want to say that Anthony
Richardson is some great passer and
Michael Pittman's got these huge games
but he's really likely in this scheme to
catch five six seven balls a week
and so I think that if people want to
give up on Michael Pittman or try to try
to sell high right now Michael Pittman
it's an interesting opportunity to buy
on him
what do you think about Michael Pittman
rest of season Leone
yeah he's running around on 98 of the
team's dropbacks his Target shares the
first two weeks this season 28 36 so we
thought there was a chance that Target
share ceiling could be high what we
didn't really I guess full hit count for
was not just the fast pace but you noted
the fastest Pace in the league and even
the pass rate for the Colts you know
their pass right over expectation is
positive we thought it could be really
negative with the rookie quarterback who
runs a lot it's positive and Anthony
Richardson has completed 64 of his
passes now it's a small sample but this
is a guy that we thought might complete
like 50 55 percent of his passes so when
you add up all those things across the
board it's really really solid for
pitman's long-term role here
fifth one is going to be a controversial
one because frustratingly Christian
Watson
has not played yet this season due to a
hamstring pull he sustained this
hamstring poll it's not like he was this
was lingering and I wanted to take him
anyways this was something that
literally popped up like two days before
the season started Christian Watson
pulled his hamstring did not play week
one did not play week two I think
they're gonna end up listening him
questionable
for week three all I'll say on this is
that if someone's 0-2 because they took
Christian Watson in the fourth round
they could be desperate right now to get
Christian Watson to get win and get
Christian Watson off their team right
and so if you're 2-0 or one and one you
have a chance to get a guy who I thought
was a really good fourth fifth round
pick this year
for less than that I think that's an
interesting move
to make Jordan love has looked I think
better than most people thought he would
yeah he's been a bit inconsistent in
terms of accuracy
but he has been efficient and he has
been aggressive
so I like krisha Watson and if the
team's Owen two again and you can get
him relatively cheaply
the only what have you thought of Jordan
love so far in any thoughts on Christian
Watson rest of season yeah Love's been
you know pretty efficient in terms of
the yards per Target or yards per
attempt there and getting downfield but
it's not a super high pass volume
offense I think the hope with Watson is
that he comes in earns a big Target
share and then benefits from that
efficiency you know there's not going to
be a huge Target guy uh in terms of law
but he gets enough of his share enough
big plays and people just get impatient
like before the season it's easy to
think about long term and you know guys
who are going to break out and then two
weeks into the year people panic and you
got to be aware of your league's playoff
structure too right like I'm in leagues
where 8 out of 12 teams make the
playoffs I'm gambling on Christian watts
and I can afford to lose a game or risk
losing a game here and there the next
few weeks in order to build a team
that's gonna be awesome in the playoffs
so I'm in a league where only 4 out of
12 teams make the playoffs I might be
you know a little bit more conservative
in pursuing Watson just you know not
totally sure what his time frame to come
back is
I just want to say uh Leone mentioned
he's in a league where eight out of 12
teams make the playoffs I just want to
say that's not American you know I I
love Leone it's Un-American okay if I'm
not the commissioner if somebody offers
you a league where where eight of 12
teams make the playoffs you tell them no
no
no I don't want to play in that kind of
lead I'm sorry I appreciate the invite
but I'm sorry all right let's jump into
the fantasy bundles presented by State
Farm we're bundling your home and auto
insurance is just another way to save
with the personal price plan
go through a couple stacks actually
we'll go through five Stacks this week
that we are interested in that we think
have a really good chance of succeeding
first one is going to be Matthew
Stafford and puka nikua I want you to be
very clear
I didn't I said it last week I'll say it
again this week is not a fluke you don't
earn 35 Targets in two games you're not
second in the entire college nation in
yards per route run without being able
to play football and win at the NFL
level also when your Matthew Stafford is
your quarterback and he thinks you're
good you have massive massive massive
fantasy upside I'm not just talking
about Calvin Johnson who set records not
just talking about Cooper Cup who set
records under Matthew Stafford guys like
Marvin Jones uh Golden Tate tutu Atwell
are having career years or had career
years with Matthew Stafford and so I
don't think this is going away man
especially with the way the defenses are
playing now short routes to guys like
puka nakua are going to be very very
profitable so I think Stafford naku is
not a fluke at all and I'll be in on
that bundle for week one here that is a
Monday night game
yeah I'll go with with a bundle I'll go
Deshawn Watson and Amari Cooper against
the Titans and we talk about pass funnel
defenses but in our data set right now
for this week we have the Titans defense
allowing the largest positive pass right
over expectation to opponents what that
means is teams are throwing against
Tennessee at a way higher rate than they
normally would given the game script and
that's because they're extremely Stout
against the run but weak in the
secondary have some injuries there so
you couple that with Nick chubb's injury
and Deshawn Watson and Cleveland they
got to go to the air a bit more so I
like you know them to bounce back after
kind of a brutal performance offensively
on Monday night yeah I mean Jerome
Ford's going to start this game and drum
4 is not going to have a lot of
efficiency success and people are going
to say drum Fort stinks I want to
caution people jump forward I don't
think stinks it's just Tennessee is very
very hard to run against expect a pass
heavy game plan out of the Browns
third one is this Lions team Jared Goff
to Josh Reynolds now we know David
Montgomery is not going to play in this
game so they're going to go with Craig
Reynolds and Jamir Gibbs a running back
I think that's going to make them lean
into a more pass heavy game plan and
when they do pass more Marvin Jones
can't play anymore they don't want to
use Khalif Raymond that much Josh
Reynolds knows Jared God for a long time
going back to their time together with
the Rams it's not that crazy to think
Josh Jones can sustain what he's been
doing and also I would note this game is
at home where jirehoff has been so much
better and this lines haven't been so
much better than it's been on the road
so goth to Reynolds is one that might be
off the board a bit but I do like it
this week any thoughts on that one
leonie
yeah I mean I like that one Reynolds had
a couple touchdowns last week helped me
uh in DFS so I was I was pretty into
that and he's I think we've seen his
role kind of grow to like a larger ADOT
kind of more efficient type thing than
he was with the Rams uh I'm gonna stick
with the Dome game theme though and go
with Kirk Cousins Justin Jefferson this
game versus the Chargers Adam has a 54
game total that's by far the highest on
the week we've got two teams that we
project for an above average amount of
plays the Chargers are always one of the
fastest paced teams in the league their
play calling is somewhat dependent on
what the other defense does well but
more times than not there they lean past
heavier and Minnesota we definitely know
leans pass heavy part of that's by
Design part of that's because they've
been so uneffective running the ball and
I expect that to continue so you know
kind of an obvious one without whenever
you have Justin Jefferson but I think
the ceiling for cousins is really high
in terms of 300 plus yards to to three
pass in TD upside yeah so I understand
that this is an obvious one anyone can
go out and say Justin Jefferson is an
awesome play I thought this was a spot
that is especially awesome for cousins
and Jefferson in the dome against a team
that plays a pass happy style also
against a team that plays very fast
um it's just set up as like one of the
better cousins Justin Jefferson spots of
the entire year
last bundle here Lamar Jackson and Zay
flowers now Odell Beckham hurt his ankle
last week which I think opens up a
little bit more for Zay flowers I just
like the way that zave flowers looks it
is being used he is getting easy targets
to go with deep targets we saw in week
one a ton of scheme stuff to say flowers
we saw in week two him catch a
50-something yard bomb
from Lamar Jackson against the Bengals
and so with Odell's ankle banged up him
possibly out it just reduces a little
bit of the competition there I know they
have Nelson Aguilar we're just a little
bit of competition there
and scheming stuff to say flowers just
make so so so much sense so that was the
fifth one there Leonia any thoughts on
the Raven stuff this week
yeah I do think too there's still some
more upside to the Ravens offense in
general we haven't seen yet just because
they've really handled you know Houston
week one and uh even Cincinnati it got a
little bit closer towards the end of the
game but they played that game
completely from ahead where if they ever
get behind I know their favorite a
decent bet against the Colts um but we
could see them really kind of air out
and run a little bit Up Tempo and I'm
hopeful that the Colts Fast Pace that
we've talked about influences Baltimore
a little bit increases the play count
and just helps all the Ravens offensive
players for Fantasy I was gonna say I
mean not only are the Colts playing very
fast they might have the worst
cornerback set in the entire NFL I mean
they are majorly lacking Talent at the
defensive cornerback and defensive
secondary positions
all right one question here from Chad
from bodos he says should I send Brian
Robinson and Zay flowers who we just
talked about to get cd-lam so my default
in these trades Leoni is like give me
the best player right give me the one
give me the best guy in the deal
obviously in this trade that's CD lamp
however Brian Robinson and Zay flowers
have been two of my favorite players
going back to the summer so this is a
hard one for me Leoni CD lamb for Brian
Robinson and Zay flowers what side do
you have there
I think you got to take the upgrade and
take CD Lam he's just too talented I
mean it's a round one talent and even
though the early Returns on Robinson and
Zay flowers are good I know Robinson's
still at some four yards per Terry he's
getting more work and the offense is
running like more Up Tempo so he's
getting like higher quality chances but
he's still not doing
you know a ton with those chances in
terms of efficiency so that's always a
little bit of flag over the course of
the season and as a result I just gotta
take you know the chance to get around
one talent for guys that you drafted in
like round seven through ten is it's too
early for me to not just take that that
Premier talent and I love Brian Robinson
I have a ton of Brian Robinson this year
when the Reds when the commanders are
trailing his role was going to be way
worse like way worse and so they haven't
really run into a game yet this year
where they're getting buried all right
let's go back to our targets to trade
for we have five more here to talk about
number six is going to be Jordan Addison
now
Jordan has is an exciting player man
round one rookie playing an extremely
past Centric offense
I think he hasn't really hit his ceiling
yet though because he's still running
less sprouts
than KJ Osborne
I don't expect that to be sticky I think
eventually before the end of the year
Jordan Addison will be running the
second most routes on this team behind
Justin Jefferson and by the way this
team only uses three wide receivers they
have not even given another wide
receiver a route this year
so I think it's going to be a really
nice end of season stretch for Jordan
Addison the one thing I'll say here
Leone though I believe the Vikings are
Owen too
if they like Wheels really come off and
they give away Kirk Cousins or something
of the trade deadline obviously that's
really bad for Jordan Addison so uh
there's some risk here that the wheels
come off Minnesota
but yeah I still like trying to acquire
him what do you think about Addison rest
of season
yeah I mean you said it they've only
played three wide receivers so even with
KJ Osborne running 95 of the team's
routes Jordan Addison's run 72 which is
an awesome sign for rookie out of the
gate he's caught a couple of long
touchdowns now I think sometimes people
are quick to say oh that's not
sustainable but I think that's the wrong
takeaway when you see a young player
achieving with high efficiency yeah it's
going to regress a little bit but the
opportunity should grow that should help
them earn more opportunities he's at
1.99 yards per out run right now which
is a really strong number KJ Osborne's
at 0.74 I mean uh he's got to overtake
Osborne and even until he does because
this team is only playing three wide
receivers and is so pass heavy he's
going to be pretty startable week to
week yeah I'm fine sorry Jordan Addison
like right away this week too if you can
get him number seven an injury popped up
before we were able to change this but
Justice Hill is probably going to miss
this week due to a turf toe injury which
is scary that might mean you could find
him on your wire at some point I think
that's interesting because the Ravens
have not despite the injury to JK
Dobbins have not shown any urgency to
upgrade their running back room you know
there's some guys out there that Kim
Acres was out there Kareem hunt was out
there obviously Larry fournette is out
there
they stuck with Justice Hill as the 1A
and Gus Edwards as the 1B last week now
yes Justin is going to be out I think
with this toe injury but I do think he
fits Todd monken's offense reasonably
well so if Justice Hill gets dropped in
your league which I think he might it's
an interesting stash I'd rather probably
stash Kendra Miller right now but
Justice Hill is certainly in the mix as
well we don't know anything about
Raven's backfield
yeah I like stashing hell if people give
up on him quickly with the injury last
week the carries were 11 for him 10 for
Gus Edwards so it seems like a split
roll but what we care about is the high
value touches those are goal line
carries targets Justice Haley two goal
line carries to Gus it's one he had
three targets to Gus is zero Justice
Hill is more likely to be what we
thought JK Dobbins could be than Gus
Edwards is I don't know if either guy is
going to be able to replicate that but
if one of them can it's got to be just
as hell
next one is a guy I'm pretty excited
about and I already mentioned how I
liked trying to go get Justin Fields I
think when Justin Fields turns it around
if he turns around it will be Roshan
Johnson as his main running back here
Roshan Johnson you notice in week two
Deontay Foreman was inactive that left
Roshan Johnson has the number two now
the Bears played so bad in Tampa you
didn't really get to see it from Roshan
but I really do think the guy can play
the reason that he did not go higher in
the NFL draft is he was buried behind
Bijan Robinson at Texas never really got
to show what he could do the Bears
already think that he's their best pass
catching best pass down running back and
I don't think it's too long before they
realize he's better than Cleo Herbert
bass as well and so Cleo Herbert in the
change of pace role Roshan Johnson in
the past damn role plus a lot of the
base work
it stinks I know the Bears are terrible
but I think that's a this is the
cheapest chance we're gonna get to get
Roshan Johnson right now Leoni any
thoughts on Bear's backfield
yeah Roshan played 40 of the snaps week
one but it was all garbage time and he
kind of impressed in that time then he
got 40 percent of snaps in week two but
these were like real snaps in a close
game you know totally iced deonta
Foreman who got a dnp and they've been
thrown into the backfield more than I
expected so I do think
um there's there's certainly some upside
there if he can LeapFrog Cleo Herbert
for a higher carry share
all right this next one man it doesn't
feel comfortable to me to be excited
about 165 pound wide receivers in the
NFL or anyone that's not if you weigh as
much as me and you're in the NFL it's
hard for me to get excited tank Dell AKA
Nathaniel Dell is 165 pounds however
however he was
outrageously productive in college like
jump off the screen at you in college
and now he's gone to the NFL and done it
in the preseason and done it in the
regular season and by done it I mean
earning targets which is hard to do at
the NFL level and being successful with
them nor Brown is out they still have
Nico Collins who's playing at high level
and Robert Woods who is a reasonable
veteran
it's pretty exciting though for tank
Dell I think because unlike Davis Mills
when it gets into garbage time CJ Stroud
can sling it man so you saw that last
week
I like adding tanked out where you can
am I too high on 165 pound wide receiver
who plays for the Texans Leone
well I know our Evan Silva for ETR has
been high on tank Dell since you know
before the season even started I don't
know if there's like quite a shower
narrative there though but there's
something with shroud lobbying for for
Dell to be to be picked but I I really
like the way this team's calling plays
much like the Colts I mean I did not
expect them to be so Up Tempo and to
trust their rookie quarterback so much
like we don't usually see that they have
a 71 pass rate through two games now
some of that's because the game script
but even accounting for game script
they're like pretty neutral in terms of
their throw rate and we should expect
them to be traveling games so if they're
willing to do that I mean the ceiling
looks pretty good for a lot of the
Houston pass catchers Nico Collins
included is someone that I really really
like right now agreed all right last guy
we're looking to trade for is going to
be a guy who hopefully you added off the
wire already and that's Jerome Ford now
the whole discussion on drum forward
seems to have changed in the public
narrative because Kareem hunt signed
with the Browns cream hunt was Jake
chubb's backup last year knows the
system can slide right in Etc I want to
be clear the Browns had
one two three five six months to bring
back cream hunt
they chose not to do so because I think
they really liked Jerome Ford they
didn't even make Jerome Ford compete for
the rb2 job behind Nick Chubb this year
they just gave it to him they didn't
make him even compete and so I think
Kareem hunt will come in as the backup
to Jerome Ford so someone picked up
Jerome Ford and they're spooked by all
the scream hunt stuff I'd be looking as
that at that as a chance to go ahead and
get Jerome Ford Leoni what do you think
about the splits and by the way I'm not
expecting big drone forward game this
week against the Titans I still want to
have them on my team what do you think
about the split though going forward
between Ford and cream hunt
yeah I think you know Ford's the number
one I don't even want to say 1A because
I think he's the clear one and Hunt will
be two anytime something like this
happens the team's gonna bring in depth
at the position like they have to it's
not an indictment on Ford in my opinion
you know
I initially I thought he might be
overvalued because he played so well on
Monday night but that now it seems to
have swung the other direction with
people reacting to the hunt news so I
think Ford's clearly a hat I think it's
possible he has a pretty bad game this
week where if you missed out on grabbing
him from the waiver wire and you want to
make a trade offer maybe maybe wait
until this game against Tennessee that's
not really favorable for opposing
running backs and and try and NAB him
then all right we have about five
minutes here before we gotta get out of
here we'll take as many questions as we
can first one from Frank Molina he says
should I start Kyron Williams Devonte
Smith or Jamir Gibbs in the flex my God
Frank hashtag how rich Kyron Williams
Devonte Smith or Jamir Gibbs I actually
want to start
all three of them I would have to
consult with our projections
to understand exactly who I'd want to
start but leonie what do you think about
this one Kyron Devonte Smith or Jamir
Gibbs
yeah so our projections for full PPR
have these guys all within half a point
of one another so it's sort of pick your
poison part of me wants to just play
Kyron Williams one more week given how
absurd the role was last week I don't
think we're gonna see you know a 10
Target game again from a running back
but just the fact that he's got that in
his wheelhouse is so huge if you can get
that amount of dump Downs plus goal line
work you know the floor ceiling
combination is pretty good so man
usually I go with the more exciting
players and like Gibbs and Smith who are
definitely like more efficiency
All-Stars but I probably lean towards
Kyron here I think he's the best floor
ceiling combination Frank you need to
make a trade buddy you need to package
two of these guys to get another
Superstar because you can't be deciding
on this every week we got to start all
three of these guys every week I think
Devonte Kyron and Gibbs are all awesome
starts Jay Guerrero says trying to move
Jerome forward for a wide receiver who
is someone that I could shoot for yeah
we publish a rest of season top one 150
every week at established the run and so
you could see wherefore it is in the
range of other wide receivers there that
you could try to shoot for I like buying
low on Jalen waddle right now I'm not
sure that Ford is enough to get Jalen
waddle but maybe you could add Ford and
someone else to get waddle the only any
ideas if you're looking to get a wide
receiver for Jerome Ford right now
yeah I mean Christian Watson was one of
the guys we had to go out and trade for
right now while people are concerned I
think Mike Williams is about to explode
and it's probably going to happen this
week in a dome game against Minnesota
and he's been somewhat quiet to start
the year so I think that'd be really
good but I'd probably be aiming to try
and hit someone in that tier you've also
got like Jerry Judy some of these guys
we really liked before this season that
have started a little bit slow but still
have super high ceilings
all right Gill has a injured star
question he says would you trade saquon
Barkley for Cooper cup straight up let
me just give my take on the injuries
here for a second I think saquon
Barkley's ankle sprain is concerning
because any ankle sprain is concerning
it doesn't sound like it's a severe one
though if he's out more than two to
three weeks I would be surprised on
Cooper cub
I mean hamstring injuries that end up on
IR with like nerve stuff being reported
he's 30 something years old concerns me
a little bit more but I do think the
ceiling is way higher on cup if he's
healthy Dan saquon we also have to mix
in though that puka is playing awesome
and that's gonna have an impact on when
Cooper cup comes back also so rest of
season Leone who would you rather have
saquon Barkley or Cooper cup
man that's tough because I think you
know a healthy cup is better than a
healthy Sequon down the stretch in terms
of the ceiling you're going to get there
but I'm definitely more concerned about
cups injury than Barclays at this point
in time so I think I'd go with Barclay
okay agreed teal says should I start
DeAndre Hopkins or Garrett Wilson
this week DeAndre Hopkins of course
coming off the ankle injury but is
practicing in full Gary Wilson is
dealing with an injury of his own that
of course is Zach Wilson being his
quarterback and so it is a problem
very tough matchup I think for Denver
Hopkins here against the good Cleveland
secondary but yeah the Zach Wilson stuff
is such a mess Leoni Garrett Wilson or
DeAndre Hopkins this week now we've also
got your least favorite elements to deal
with in fantasy football this weekend
Adam which is uh East Coast weather uh
which seems like it could possibly
impact this Jets New New England game I
wouldn't you know go overboard on the
weather I mean the Tennessee Cleveland
game uh in Cleveland doesn't look great
either but I think if Hopkins is full
practice Thursday and Friday I'd go him
just because I think the target share is
safer to be really high but it's an
unfortunate spot with both these guys
right now with Hopkins being injured and
and Wilson having to deal with Wilson uh
because I think they're going to be both
pretty low volume pass offenses on the
whole um Garrett's more likely to break
off a random big play like we saw last
week but DeAndre Hopkins is more likely
to get peppered with Target so that's
the way I'm gonna lean
no offense to my friends in Cleveland is
the weather ever good there every time I
play someone in Cleveland I get buried
by the weather wind rain cold I mean
Jesus it's not it's unbelievable
two more questions here to get to I need
more bounces should I start Hunter Henry
or Zach ertz as my tight end this week
Hunter was a guy that I was super high
on before the year that's been good so
far Zach Hertz was a guy that I was
super super low on wouldn't even draft
him in the 20th round turns out that I
believe he leads all tight ends in
targets right now he does not do much
with them though Leonia what do you
think about Hunter Henry for Zach Earth
straight up this week
yeah Target's and air yard leader at
tight end is going to be
back hurts and uh man that that's a
tough one as a result I'm trying to look
at our projections real quick but I
think I'd probably go hunter Henry who's
you know started off hot I think he has
a bit more touchdown upside than Zach
ertz does but
we saw like last week you know sometimes
even if you're not a very good player
which I don't think Zach cards is at
this point in his career if you get that
opportunity weekend week oh you're just
gonna fall into some good weeks um still
though I'm gonna go hunter Henry here
yeah I mean Zachary's might go out and
get eight nine targets against the
Cowboys
fantasy points per Target on that is
going to be so so so low I think Hunter
Henry also David says would you try and
move on from Isaiah Pacheco or Rashad
white to get a better running back so I
think that this past week will be one of
Rashad White's better games of the
Season he was facing the bears but the
role is so good and they do not seem to
have a lot of faith in Sean Tucker
particularly on pass down so yeah I
don't know man I mean it depends what
you could get but it's hard to find
running backs with the role that Rashad
white has right now Pacheco I think is
gonna have an awesome week this week
against the Bears I'd wait to trade
Pacheco until after this week you don't
need any thoughts on Pacheco and Rashad
white rest of season
I'm the exact same thoughts as you and
Rashad white like I'm pretty worried
about him because the efficiency's been
so bad the role's been good enough to
prop him up but we see this a lot where
it's just that can only last so long and
Sean Tucker's looming a little bit there
the issue is I'm not really sure like
what a good trade is like maybe if you
could get Jerome Ford
um Brian Robinsons probably start off
too hot to get him but Javonte Williams
has been a little bit quiet there's been
some good signs there
um that's the type of or even Kyron
Williams like jumping on him I think
those guys are better bets rest the
season than Rashad White
all right that is going to do it for
this week's fantasy football live on
Bleacher Report presented
by State Farm I appreciate all you guys
being here all you guys being here and
chat all our rankings and projections at
establishtherun.com will be updated
continuously through lock
for everyone behind the scenes at
bleacher report for everyone behind the
scenes
at State Farm for Leone
I am Adam
good luck in week three